DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Morning
everyone.
I hope the keynote was good.
My name is Dror Shimshowitz.
AJ CRANE: And I am AJ Crane.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: And we're with
the YouTube product team.
We work on creators
and curators.
And we're here to tell you how
to get with the program.
Lots of the talks at I/O, over
the next couple days, will be
super technical, lots
of API discussions.
But today, we're going to talk
to you about the softer side
of things, how you can use
YouTube as a great content
platform in order to tell the
world about your company and
your startup.
So let me just take
a quick poll.
Who here, their company, has
a YouTube channel already?
Can you raise your hand?
It's about 2/3.
That's more than I expected.
What about a Google+ page?
Facebook fan page?
Twitter handles?
Everybody, especially
for the latter ones.
So the first question I'd like
to ask is, how come everybody
has a Google+ page and a Twitter
handle, but not a
YouTube channel?
AJ CRANE: Well, it might
be because making
video is really hard.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So that's
exactly the myth that we want
to dispel today, that you too
can start creating videos and
get your own YouTube
channel going.
And in order to prove that
point, we wanted to start off
by going down to Ojai,
California and check in with a
local business down there, who
has been using YouTube very
successfully, over
the past year.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You probably thought this
deer was alive, and this
coyote was alive, and this
pheasant was alive.
Nope.
They're not They're dead.
They've been taxidermised
by Chuck
Testa, Ojai Valley Taxidermy.
I specialize in the most
life-like dead animals
anywhere, period.
-Look at that antelope
driving a car.
-Nope.
It's just Chuck Testa.
-Oh no, there's a
bear in my bed!
-Nope.
Chuck Testa.
-Hold on a second.
[GROWL]
There's a leopard feeding on
an impala out on my deck.
-Nope.
It's just Chuck Testa with
another realistic mount.
Ship to me from anywhere.
Call Chuck Testa for the
most lifelike dead
animals around, period.
-Did that rhino just
order a drink?
-Nope.
-Check Testa does not
taxidermise pets.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: And if we go
below, we see he's gotten 12
million views.
So in all seriousness, the point
is, if a local business
in Ojai, California, which is
not super high tech, can make
good use of YouTube, then we
think you can as well.
So what we're going to do today
is, first, we're going
to catch you up on all the
latest and greatest with
YouTube, show you how far we've
gotten with the product.
Then the heart of the
presentation, we'll talk to
you about all the great ways
that you can use YouTube for
your startup and your company.
And then we'll wrap it up with
some more tactical tips and
tricks and then open
it up to questions.
So first, how far has YouTube
gotten in the last few years?
YouTube is now watched by most
people on the web each month.
Whether they are coming the
directly to the site, or they
watch our embedded player, which
is on lots of sites and
blogs throughout the web, lots
and lots of people consume
online video.
And most of those people
are consuming
YouTube content today.
It's a huge audience, and
it continues to grow.
And in fact, YouTube is now the
third-largest site on the web.
So think about, if your company
is not on YouTube,
you're not on the third largest
site, you're not on
the second-largest search
engine on the web.
Beyond coming directly to the
site, when people watch
YouTube videos, they
love to share them.
This is very social content.
And so, whether it's 700 videos
shared on Twitter every
minute or on other social
platforms or people just
emailing and sharing out links
in lots of different ways,
this content is inherently
viral.
And even if a consumer doesn't
have a habit of coming to
YouTube each day-- like maybe
my mom, she's not a big
YouTube user--
I'm sending her videos all the
time, and she watches them,
because I'm her son, and
I sent it to her.
So YouTube is increasingly
getting in front of most of
the consumers and the viewers
on the web, whether or not
they come directly
to the site.
Another important thing to
realize is that YouTube is now
far more than a website.
We're on most of the phones out
there, over 350 million,
pre-installed on
a lot of them.
And mobile viewing of
the site is growing
by leaps and bounds.
It's tripled in just
the last year.
And I think it's clearly a
question of when, not if,
mobile viewing of YouTube
videos will
surpass desktop viewing.
So if you take a step back,
and you think about people
watching YouTube videos, not
just on the site, but on
embedded players throughout the
web, and increasingly on
their phones, and now
increasingly in the living
room, where YouTube is on more
and more connected devices
from Google TV to Xbox to things
like the Q, YouTube
will just become a pervasive
part of people's lives.
And not only will we have 800
million and growing users
every month, but even throughout
their day, they're
going to watch more and
more YouTube content.
So to show the spirit of what
this pervasive YouTube
environment might look like, we
put together a quick demo.
So let me show it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[AUDIO NEWS CLIPS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So hopefully,
that gives you a
sense of the increasing
deployment of video screens in
our world and in our life and
what it's like for consumers
to have YouTube at their
fingertips, morning,
afternoon, and evening.
So now, let's think about how
you guys and your companies
can make the best use
of this platform.
So let me turn it over to AJ.
AJ CRANE: So hopefully Dror has
convinced you that YouTube
is the best platform for
connecting with the world, on
hundreds of millions of
devices, using video.
But you might be thinking, I
don't need to connect with the
whole world.
And I've never made
a single video.
So today, we want to give you
some ideas for creating videos
and how you can connect
your business
with the right audience.
So the key to success on
YouTube is content.
So without any content on
YouTube, your brand is
invisible to this increasingly
massive audience.
But most people don't have much
experience creating video.
So we wanted to share a couple
ideas to get you guys started.
So if you remember one thing
from today's presentation, it
should be this.
People don't come to YouTube
to catch up on the latest
commercials.
They come to be entertained
and informed.
And they're always just one
click away from other enticing
related videos, so it's really
important that you make your
videos engaging and something
that people
actually want to watch.
So this means creating content
and not creating commercials.
So to test this out, we wanted
to show you guys two 15-second
clips of different videos and
then have you guys vote on
which one you want to
watch the rest of.
So here's the first.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You've never seen a shaver
like this before.
It's the new 3M Surgical
Clipper by Remington.
Hospitals are now using it,
replacing blades, to shave
patients for surgery safely
and comfortably.
And you can benefit from this
advanced technology
by using the Rem--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: All right,
remember it.
And here is the second.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, I'm Mike, founder of
DollarShaveClub.com.
What is DollarShaveClub.com?
Well, for $1 a month, we send
high-quality razors
right to your door.
Yeah!
$1!
Are the blades any good?
No.
Our blades are [BLEEP]
great.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: All right, so
quick show of hands.
Who would rather see
the second video?
Yes.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Should
we watch the end of it?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
So this is really typical
of how our
YouTube audience works.
So if you don't hook them within
the first 15 seconds,
it's really easy for them
to leave your content.
So it's super important that
you hook them in the first
couple seconds.
So here's the rest of
DollarShaveClub.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Each razor has stainless steel
blades, an aloe vera
lubricating strip,
and a pivot head.
It's so gentle a toddler
could use it.
And do you like spending $20 a
month on brand-name razors?
$19 go to Roger Federer.
I'm good at tennis.
And do you think your razor
needs a vibrating handle, a
flashlight, a back scratcher,
and 10 blades?
Your handsome-ass grandfather
had one blade and polio.
Looking good, papa.
Stop paying for shave-tech
you don't need.
And stop forgetting to buy
your blades every month.
Alejandro and I are going to
ship then right to you.
We're not just selling razors,
we're also making new jobs.
Alejandro, what were you
doing last month?
-Not working.
-What are you doing now?
-Working.
-I'm no Vanderbilt, but
this train makes hay.
[TRAIN WHISTLE]
So stop forgetting to buy your
blades every month and start
deciding where you're going to
stack all those dollar bills
I'm saving you.
We are DollarShaveClub.com,
and the party is on.
[PARTY MUSIC]
-Hi, I'm Mike.
Hi, I'm Mike.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: So making great videos
isn't just about making
people laugh.
Video can also be used to help
your business in lots of ways.
So first, it's important to
think about what your goal is.
So since you're here at I/O, we
thought that we might have
a lot of companies that are
getting started, so we chose
to focus on these three goals.
First is just getting the word
out about your brands and
raising awareness.
Second, using video
to raise money.
And then third, using video to
learn more about what your
audience thinks about your
product or service.
So let's start with PR.
The obvious first video for any
new company to create is a
product video that explains
exactly what your product does
and how it works.
These product videos are really
great for you to share
with any of the press or
bloggers that might be
covering the launch of
your new product.
The reason being is having a
video included in the blog
post actually makes sure that
your message is clear and that
none of the important features
or functionality is overlooked
when the article is released.
Because there's nothing more
frustrating than having your
favorite feature not be
included when the
news story comes out.
So here's an example of a
company named CakeHealth that
put together a great video
to be included in
a TechCrunch article.
So including the video in the
article is not only great for
you, as the product owner, to
make sure that nothing gets
lost, but it's also great
for the bloggers.
So having a video makes it
really easy to make sure that
your story's on point and that
you're not missing anything.
So while the product videos
are great, you can't
just stop at one.
It's not a one-time thing.
Instead, this should be an
ongoing thing as you develop
new features.
So this is especially important
for really complex
products that are better said
broken into more digestible
chunks for today's increasingly
ADD audience.
Salesforce has done a really
good job of this.
They actually have almost 3,000
videos on their channel
and have accumulated 9
million views, across
all of those videos.
And this is almost as effective
for them as a second
sales force.
And if you come to think of
it, videos are a very
cost-effective way to generate
sales leads.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: What if your
audience [INAUDIBLE] or they
just don't have that
attention span?
AJ CRANE: Good question.
So animation is a great
fit for certain
products and audiences.
So back at the Tube, we recently
launched a feature
called suggested edits.
And so this feature is really
targeted at the kind of user
who doesn't want to download
editing software, doesn't want
to watch tutorials and
screencasts on how to use that
editing software.
Instead, they just want to click
a button and have their
video work.
So instead of doing a
screencast, we created this
quick, fun, 30-second animation
that got the message
of the new feature across
in a super casual way.
So let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hey, you.
Enjoy uploading videos to
YouTube, but have problems
with shaky footage?
YouTube now automatically
detects problems with your
videos and can color correct and
stabilize shaky footage.
So you can worry more about
free-falling, ten-hanging,
two-wheeling, top-roping,
pet-wrangling, and
face-planting, and less
about a steady camera.
So keep those videos rolling
in, and keep an eye out for
more innovations from
the YouTube team.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: So animation is also
great if you're a little
camera shy.
It's a great way to not have
your face on camera but still
get the message across.
The other thing you might be
thinking is, I don't have the
budget to create an animation
like this.
So stop motion is also
a great alternative.
And I'm going to show you
guys an example of
that in a couple minutes.
So in addition to product
videos, you can also use
sight, sound, and motion to get
the word out about your
brands without even mentioning
your product.
So Etsy, as some of you might
know, is a really awesome
platform that allows artisans
from all over the world to
sell their products online.
While the platform and the
technology is super cool, the
best thing about Etsy is this
huge community of artisans
that makes them unique.
So what they've done in their
channel is, instead of
uploading product videos,
they've created videos that
tell the backstory about
their brand and add
color to their community.
So here's a quick one from
one of their artists.
And you'll notice that the video
barely mentions Etsy.
But still there's a lot for
improving the awareness of
their brand.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I think, in general, there's
a reaction against digital
technologies.
They don't seem very personal.
And they don't seem very
different from each other.
And I think people
are looking for
something that's different.
There is definitely a
relationship between a person
who wears a mechanical watch
and the watch itself.
Because you are winding it,
you're giving something to the
relationship, and you're getting
something back again.
I'm David Sokosh, and I'm the
owner of Brooklyn Watches.
I owned an art gallery in--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: So that should just
give you an idea of the kind
of content they're uploading.
It's really great.
So if you still have no idea
of what you might want to
create content about and what
kind of content will suit your
brand, Dror is going to share
some ideas on how you can get
inspired and get some ideas
for your next video.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So one thing
we think is really important,
if you're going to create
content for YouTube, is that
you just be familiar with what
content is already on YouTube.
So what we do at work all
day is we watch videos.
That's really a tough
part of our job.
And we're accepting
applications, because we need
more people to watch videos of
cats and things like that.
But it's actually really
important to, at least, get a
taste of what the community and
the YouTube audience is
already watching.
But if you don't have time all
day to watch YouTube videos,
we have a few tools that can
help you quickly come up to
speed on what's popular.
So the first is we maintain a
blog called YouTube Trends.
And we have a team that scours
YouTube and sites all over the
web to see what's popular,
what's trending, and tries to
pick up the memes fairly early
and bring them to the
attention of the audience for
the YouTube Trends blog.
So I encourage you guys to
follow that blog, every day.
About four times a day,
they update the site.
You can also go into
YouTube Charts.
And for each category, each
vertical, each type of
content, you can see what's
been the most popular.
So for comedy or sports or
different topics, you can see
what's worked really well.
Now, if you want to get
even more analytical--
actually, before I talk about
analytical, I want to talk
about cats.
So there are a lot of cat
videos on YouTube.
And they do all sorts of
interesting things.
And so you might wonder, how
do these cats come up with
what they're going
to do on video?
Well, we think that they watch
YouTube, and they copy what
other cats are doing.
So we encourage you guys
to do the same.
But if you want to be more
analytical about it, our real
power tool is the Trends
Dashboard, especially if you
know what audience you're
going after.
So let's say your product is
targeting Buffalo or is
targeting males that are 15 to
24, you can dive in, slice and
dice the data, and see which
videos are appealing to that
demographic.
You can go to different cities,
different countries,
and just see what's playing
well across the world.
And this can be really powerful
for helping you
understand your intended
audience.
So if you're still not inspired,
and you still don't
know what kind of content to
create, or you don't have the
budget, or you don't have the
time, the next thing that you
should look at is the
community itself.
There's a very vibrant
community on YouTube.
And there's a chance that
they're already creating
content for you.
So here's an example of a
channel called Rokenbok.
This is a company that makes
small, toy trucks.
They are really fun.
And their users are constantly
uploading videos to YouTube,
playing with the little,
remote control trucks.
And what Rokenbok has done is,
they have found these videos
across YouTube.
They've pulled them together
into a playlist, that they
call Customer Videos and put
it on their channel.
And they have, essentially,
outsourced the production of
video to their users and
their community.
All free of charge.
So this is a great tactic.
We call this curation.
And we'll come back to some
other ways that you can curate
content later.
Now, if you don't already have
a vibrant community like
Rokenbok, then you should
think about potentially
creating one.
So a lot of you guys may know
Fred from Saturday Night Live.
He just started a channel
a couple months ago.
And he uploaded a video with
a few simple instructions--
we'll watch it in a second--
in order to get a
community going.
So let's take a look
at what he did.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, I'm Fred.
I'm doing a project called "Be
Serious for 30 Seconds." And
what it is, is user-submitted
videos.
That's you.
Send in a video, and it's got
to follow these rules.
Number one, it has
to be serious.
There cannot be any comedy
whatsoever in it, no humor, no
smiles, not even, like,
ironic comedy.
It has to be 30 seconds
or less.
It can have no more than
two people in it.
There has to be at least one
five-second dramatic pause,
five seconds of total silence.
There has to be one cutaway
of an object.
You have to do your best
acting job possible.
And then the last thing
is, it has to
end with a door slamming.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Got that?
But this has actually
worked really well.
In just the last two months,
he's gotten close to 300
submissions.
These videos have been viewed
almost half a million times.
And he has jump started
this community.
And I think we can learn some
interesting things from this.
The first is that a quarter of
the people who submitted
videos were first-time
uploaders to YouTube.
They had never created
a video before.
But because Fred gave them this
sandbox, this kind of
construct, and seven very
explicit instructions on what
to do with a 30-second video,
he motivated them and gave
them a framework to work with.
And all of a sudden, they were
creating and uploading.
Also, if people upload to
YouTube, and they don't have a
large audience already, then
they may think, nobody will
watch my video.
But if you can provide the
community for them, you can
bring an audience and say, if
you create videos with our
products, we'll pull them into
our channel, and we'll show
our larger audience, then that
motivates people to create
videos for you.
So this is a really interesting
tactic.
And if you have passionate users
of your product, then we
encourage you to try and build a
video community around that.
So actually let's watch one
of the submissions.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[SPEAKING GERMAN]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Simple.
That was a submission
from Germany.
This brings up another really
interesting tactic that works
well on YouTube, which
is leveraging
other people's community.
If your channel doesn't yet
have a lot of subscribers,
then we encourage you to find
other channels, which are
relevant for your product,
that already
have a lot of followers.
So what we find on YouTube are
a lot of review sites,
especially in the
tech industry.
And these sites, these channels,
are really popular
on YouTube.
A couple examples are ijustine
and TechnoBuffalo.
And they have hundreds of
thousands of subscribers.
And what you can do is, you
can reach out to these
bloggers, you can send them
video, send them content about
your company or products.
And they love hearing
from people.
They love getting content that
they can then feature and
create videos for their
own audience.
So a running theme throughout
all of this is, don't just try
to go it alone, in terms of
getting an audience and
creating content.
Think about YouTube as a more
collaborative community to
accomplish a lot of
these things.
And then finally, once you
have some viewers on your
videos, it's not just about
raising awareness, but you can
also drive those eyeballs
back to your site.
So let's take a look at
what's that Zagg did.
They're an advertiser
on the site.
And they've done a very
effective job in driving
viewers back to their
own site.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So you see
very heavy use of branding and
then, on the bottom of the video
was an annotation that
they overlaid.
And those are actually
clickable.
And they can take [INAUDIBLE]
back to your site.
If I clicked on that, it
would go to Zagg.com.
And this is a feature that we'll
be opening up soon to
all channels where, if you have
verified your domain with
Webmaster Tools, then you'll
be able to link, from your
video, directly in the video
itself, back to your site.
So we just went through a lot
of content, so I wanted to
summarize real quick.
Raising awareness is probably
the number-one use case for a
lot of people using YouTube.
And in order to do that
effectively, we think it
should be an integral
part of your PR.
Focus on creating a lot
of product demos.
But don't just talk
about the product.
Also talk about the backstory
and add some color and
authenticity to your videos.
Use the site to get
inspired, see what
other people are doing.
Really leverage the community
in lots of different ways.
And then once you've built up
an audience and views on
YouTube, be sure to drive them
back to your site, where you
can sell them products or more
deeply engage with them.
But raising awareness is not
the only thing you can do.
So let me hand it back to A.J.,
who can tell you how
YouTube videos can help
you fundraise as well.
AJ CRANE: So video is also
emerging as a really popular
way to pitch a company to
potential investors.
Filming a video allows you to
make your message really
clear, demo your product,
introduce people to your team,
all using a video without buying
a single plane ticket,
hopping on the 101, or, worst
case scenario, putting on a
suit, going to an office.
So let's take a look at this
company called Pebble that put
together a fundraising project
on Kickstarter and created
this video as part
of the project.
So here's the video
they included.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, Kickstarter.
My name is Eric.
This is my smartphone.
And this my Pebble.
Pebble is a watch that
you can customize.
It runs a lot of cool and
useful apps and connects
wirelessly, by Bluetooth, to
your iPhone or Android
smartphone.
This is our dream team.
It started with a prototype
built from cellphone parts.
That led us to our first
commercial product, the
Impulse Smartwatch,
for BlackBerry.
The number-one question we
received was, when will the
watch work with my iPhone?
Well, we're proud to
say that we can
finally answer that question.
This is Pebble.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: So as you can see,
they explain the product.
They introduce the team.
They told their backstory and
also mention some obstacles
that they're overcoming.
It actually worked
great as a pitch.
And it was a success.
So their Kickstarter project
ended up raising over $10
million for the company, which
was much more than they had as
their target.
The other interesting fact about
including video in your
Kickstarter pitch is that
pitches that include a video
raise nearly double as much
money as those that don't.
This is a stat from Indigogo.
So the Pebble video was pretty
well produced, very clear, and
they clearly had some great
equipment doing it.
But you don't only need to
have these well-produced
videos in order to
pitch a project.
Here's another example from a
company called MaKey MaKey
that creates keyboard
input devices.
And they created a really
fun, stop-motion video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AJ CRANE: So this is also a
great example of creating
content and not commercials.
So this is, obviously, very
entertaining to watch, and
also was very successful
in their pitch.
So YouTube recently announced
a new feature where you can
actually link off to a
Kickstarter project or an
Indigogo project using the
annotations that Dror just
mentioned, that overlay
your videos.
So now I'm going to hand it
back over to Dror to talk
about how you can use video to
learn more from your audience.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So everything
we've talked about
thus far is going outward,
broadcasting to the world.
But YouTube is a
two-way medium.
And it's a great chance to
interact with users and hear
from them as well.
So if you have users of your
product already, we encourage
you to start using various
features of YouTube to better
connect with them and
better service them.
The first thing we want to
talk about is tutorials.
So if your product is very
visual or very complex, and
it's hard to explain in a help
center, it might be best to
shoot a screencast and show
visually exactly how it works.
Or if your audience doesn't have
a lot of time or doesn't
want to read through help center
articles, it's also a
great tactic.
So, in this case, we
have drchrono.
They create iPad apps
for doctors.
And doctors probably aren't
going to read instruction
manuals or go through
your help center.
But in a very short tutorial--
a minute and 21 seconds--
they explain to them how to
electronically sign the
documents in their app.
So they chunk things up into
little units, make it very
digestible, and show exactly
where, in the app, they need
to do what.
And this is very effective.
Also, if you have a developer
community in your platform for
other companies, it's a great
tool, where you can teach the
community, and then they can
also take the assets and teach
their own customers as well.
How many folks are familiar
with Google+ Hangouts?
Great.
We love Hangouts.
And we've been starting to use
it a lot for Google products.
So Google Developers Live, over
the past couple weeks,
has been holding dozens and
dozens of Hangouts.
And a lot of Google products and
Google product teams are
using this as a way to connect
with users, better explain the
product, hear feedback.
And you can even conduct focus
groups using these Hangouts.
One thing that you should
consider doing is holding
regular office hours.
So you can say to your users,
every Tuesday, from 9:00 to
11:00, we'll be hanging out.
And it doesn't matter where
you are in the world,
you can patch in.
You can ask us questions.
And it's a great way to support
your users and also
show more of the human
side of your company.
Now, we know that the
limitation on
Hangouts is 10 people.
And you may have a
lot more users.
And so there's a fairly new
feature called Hangouts On Air
where you can live stream your
Hangout on your YouTube
channel for the entire world.
And so that's not limited
to 10 people.
As many people who want
to watch the live
stream can do so.
You can also choose to make the
recording of the Hangout
On Air available on
your channel.
And so, if Tuesday 9:00 AM is
actually middle of the night
in Tokyo, somebody can still
come in, on their own time,
and listen to the Hangout and
get access to that information
as well, whenever they
want, in the future.
There are other ways to conduct
research on YouTube
instead of doing actual
focus groups.
So the first is, I mentioned
before, YouTube is the second
largest search engine.
You should go in and search
for your company and your
products and see if there's
already existing
content on the site.
So here's an example of a
company called AR Drone.
By the way, they are in the
YouTube Sandbox the rest of
I/O, so I encourage you
to check them out.
And there are lots and lots of
people uploading unboxing
videos and videos using the
AR Drone hovercraft.
And these are great, because
when you watch these videos,
as the creators of the product,
you can see, how are
people reacting when they
first get the product?
What's confusing?
What's exciting?
These videos are completely
unsolicited, so
they're very genuine.
And you can see exactly how
your users are using your
product without having to pay
them or set up focus groups or
ask them questions, which might
be leading questions.
And so we encourage you
to use this tactic.
Let's take a very quick look at
one of the unboxing videos,
just to get a flavor of it.
So I skipped forward to about
10 minutes into the video.
Here we see some annotations
that the user has added.
And we'll just watch
a little bit.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-There we go.
It's my living room.
So its should be--
start.
And we're off.
Fairly loud.
I don't know if you
can hear me.
And makes quite the breeze.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Quite
the breeze.
Maybe that could be a marketing
campaign for them in
the future.
The other great product that we
have, that most people may
not be familiar with, is
YouTube Analytics.
So it's like Google Analytics,
but it's for the video content
that you create.
And there are a few things
that you can do
with YouTube Analytics.
The first is you can see where
your audience is coming from.
So if you have videos on
YouTube, and people watch
them, you can see what
cities and countries
are they coming from.
You can see what their
demographics are, in terms of
age and gender.
Just for example,
we have a lot of
music artists on YouTube.
And they put up their videos.
And then they notice that their
music is being watched
in countries like Sweden, even
though they've never marketed
there, they've never
been there.
And so we've heard of a lot of
cases where artists decide to
go on tour and go visit some of
these communities, because
they have found a
new audience.
So a lot of you may be building
products, which you
think are intended for the
US, but may have a
great, global audience.
And YouTube analytics can show
you exactly where your
audience is coming from.
Another great thing you can see
on Analytics is the source
of traffic for your videos.
So where are your videos
coming from?
Are they all coming
from Search?
Or are there certain sites or
other YouTube channels that
are driving a lot of traffic?
So if you remember back to
ijustine and TechnoBuffalo, if
you see that some of these
channels are driving a lot of
viewers to you, you probably
want to pick up the phone and
get in touch with
these channels.
They're sending you
a lot of traffic.
You could probably deepen that
relationship and get even more
love from them.
The other thing you can do with
Analytics is you can look
inside the video.
And in this particular case, we
see a chart that shows the
drop off curve of how people
watch the video.
This was interesting for
a couple reasons.
The first is, as a video
creator, you can see what's
engaging about the video.
And you can continually hone
your craft and figure out how
to make better videos
going forward.
But you can also put different
products and features
throughout your video and use
this, as a proxy, to see what
are people interested in.
If people are always skipping
between minute three and four,
maybe they don't like the
features or what you're
talking about in that video.
And that's very cheap market
research for your product
development.
So we threw a lot at you.
And we want you to remember
some of this stuff.
So we're going to pause here, in
terms of all the different
goals and use cases that you
can use YouTube for.
But before we turn it over for
questions, we did want to go
through some more tactical items
for how to really make
your YouTube channel shine.
AJ CRANE: So as we saw in the
beginning of the session, lots
of you have YouTube channels.
But just as a quick refresher,
for those who don't know much
about channels, every user who
has ever uploaded a video on
YouTube has a channel.
And this is both your identity,
across the site, and
the landing page for users to
find and browse your videos.
So once you've built a brand
through your content, it's
also really important that you
can brand your channel page as
well and that it matches
your brand off YouTube.
So Rokenbok, the company that
Dror mentioned before, has
done a really great
job of this.
It's really clear to see what
their brand is and calls to
action, back to their site,
where you can go buy the toy.
And lo and behold, Chuck
Testa has also done an
awesome job at this.
Chuck Testa has a
really on-target
background image here.
He's got a taxidermised bear
wearing sunglasses.
And it fits really well with his
personality and his brand.
And so his channel is a great
way to let that shine through.
One more thing that Chuck does
really well, that we wanted to
mention here, is having a
consistent upload schedule.
So this is something
that we tell all of
our creators to do.
Just like I need to know when a
new Mad Men episode is going
to reappear on my DVR, it's
also great to know when my
favorite channels on YouTube
are going to
be adding new content.
So this gives them a consistent
time to come back
to your channel each week.
So Chuck does Taxidermy
Tuesdays, and it works out
really well for him.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Now, if you're
not uploading every
week, and you just can't get
into that regular cadence,
this is, again, where you can
use curation to really fill
out your channel.
GoPro, the small camera maker,
does a great job of this.
They continually find videos
that other people have made,
using GoPro cameras, and they
pull them into their channel
by commenting on them.
So this does a couple things.
It fills their channel feed with
fresh content, every day.
But it's also providing a
shout-out to the community.
In the case of the first video
they say, sick edit.
Thanks for sharing.
It really helps tie the
community together.
The other thing that you really
need to do, beyond
creating videos, is engaging
with your audience.
So in the top left, we see
that Chuck Testa is
continually replying
to comments.
He's on his channel at least
a couple times a week.
And even if it's just throwing
a "nope" on there to keep
things on his message and let
viewers know that he's
around-- he didn't just post
these videos a year ago and
hasn't been back since--
this can be really effective.
In the bottom right, we
see the Fine Bros.
They're very popular vloggers
on YouTube.
And they do a couple interesting
things with the
video down here.
The first is they picked up on
Chuck Testa as a meme, and
they played off it.
So they showed the Chuck
Testa video to kids and
filmed their reaction.
And they got a couple million
views on this video, being
inspired by another creator.
But then you also see,
in the blue--
maybe it's hard to
read the font--
they ask viewers to submit
suggestions for what videos
they should create next.
And this is a very effective
tool, very effective
technique, to both tell your
audience that you're including
them, that they get to decide
what content gets created in
the channel.
And it also improves the odds
that the next video that you
can create will be relevant to
your audience, because you
have asked them, and they have
given you suggestions.
And then finally, a lot of folks
may think they need to
get fancy video equipment,
whether it's cameras or
editing suites, things
like that.
Our suggestion to you is
to just get started.
We've been designing and
investing a lot in YouTube
tools, so that even people
shooting with shaky cellphone
cameras can quickly upload their
content to the site.
And we have a lot of free tools
to stabilize, color
correct, trim.
So it's much more important
to get started and
get content on there.
And the free tools on the site
can make it look fine.
And then if you're ready, with a
large audience, to invest in
more sophisticated equipment,
you can do
that at a later point.
So finally, just a few resources
for after today.
The Creator Hub is the single
place that you should start,
if you're looking for all sorts
of links on the various
things we've talked about.
We also have a Creator Playbook,
which is 100-page
PDF you can download.
And it goes through lots of case
studies, many more than
we're able to touch on today.
The Trends Dashboard that
we mentioned before.
And then finally, we have a
special section of YouTube
just for Developers.
And for developers, there are
going to be four other talks,
all but the 4 o'clock
will be here today.
And you could learn all about
the API and lots of other
great ways of using YouTube
in your own
applications and sites.
So final word goes to Chuck
Testa, who wants to remind you
to make content and
not commercials.
Hopefully, we gave you guys
some great ideas.
And we really want you to get
going and start creating
videos and connecting with
your users in the world
through video content.
Thanks for coming.
And now we'll open it
up for questions.
And anyone who asks a question
gets a fancy YouTube sock,
also known as a Tube sock, which
is also very important
to wear while you're
filming videos.
AJ CRANE: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Oh sorry, if
you could, please, go to the
mic to ask your question, which
is right behind you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So let's say I have
this great YouTube video, and
I want to reach out
to my audience.
What are the things I should do
after I create the video?
What should I do next?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So merely
uploading a video to YouTube
may not be enough, especially if
you don't yet have a lot of
subscribers to your channel.
So we encourage you to
do a few things.
The first is share the video on
social networks, Google+,
Facebook, Twitter.
In fact, you can connect all
those accounts to your YouTube
account and automatically have
your content syndicated to all
those platforms.
And then find channels that
might find your video relevant
and communicate with them.
They usually have their contact
information somewhere
on their channel page,
so reach out to them.
Say, hey, here's a new
video I created.
Are you willing to feature
me in your channel?
A more advanced approach is to
do a collaboration, where you
create a video together with
them, and it gets featured on
their channel and shown to
their large audience.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So after you get
started, and you've got a
number of communities together,
and a number of
people adding their
videos to it.
If you get some negative videos,
do you have, as your
channel owner, the ability
to block or take
those videos down?
AJ CRANE: You don't have
the ability to block
user-generated content that
might be about your brand,
uploaded by someone else, unless
it contains copyrighted
material that you own
the rights to.
But in general--
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: What
you include in your
channel is up to you.
So the playlist that you create
and the things that you
comment on and add into your
channel is your explicit
action to do that.
So you don't have to include
any negative videos
that are out there.
AJ CRANE: And another idea is
to include a video response.
So if someone has created a
negative video, you could do a
video response and try
and turn it around.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for actually
monetizing the video itself,
if you're making an
entertainment video, not
necessarily an advertisement
for the product that you're
doing, what would you suggest
be good ideas for monetizing
the video itself?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: So a
very timely question.
We have the YouTube
Partner Program.
Partners are video creators
who monetize on the site.
And we're now opening that
up to just about anyone.
So as long as your account is in
good standing, meaning you
haven't violated the terms of
service of the site, you're
not uploading pirated material,
then you can go into
your video manager, opt in to
become a YouTube Partner.
And we will start sharing
revenue with you right away.
So I encourage you to
look into that.
AUDIENCE: Similar question,
like the previous one.
Except become the YouTube
partner, or as a YouTube
Partner, can I use the space as
an advertisement, like in
the design or somewhere?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: You mean the
background around the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the bar.
AJ CRANE: So it's against out
terms of service to sell your
background image or your
annotations to an advertiser.
But you can use those as
supported branding or
value-add to whoever might
be your sponsor.
AUDIENCE: That's possible?
As a supported value-add
it is OK?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: As long
as it's not technically
advertising.
But the most effective
advertising on YouTube is
video advertising.
That has the highest CPMs.
And so the pre-rolls in front
of the videos are what make
the most money.
And if you become a YouTube
partner, and you opt into that
ad format, that's how to best
monetize your content.
AUDIENCE: One more question,
then [INAUDIBLE].
So regarding the video
advertisement, can I select my
own videos for that?
AJ CRANE: For?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: For the ads?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for ads.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: No.
So we use AdWords for video.
It's an auction.
And it finds the highest
monetizing and most relevant
videos for the audience.
And it may be different
for different people
watching your video.
For example, if they're from a
different country, or if they
have different interests, based
on their watch history,
we may serve up different ads.
And that system tries to
optimize both the advertising
revenue and the user
experience.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have two
quick questions.
One, I ended up creating our
YouTube channel for our
company way back when.
And now we have 100-plus
videos.
But it's associated to
my Gmail account.
I don't want that anymore.
AJ CRANE: So soon, we'll
have a solution for
you, coming very soon.
But that's been kind
of legacy issue.
But we're working towards some
more Google+ integration that
will allow you to have multiple
admins for each channel--
AUDIENCE: And that was
my other question.
AJ CRANE: --and also
own multiple
channels with one account.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
AJ CRANE: But we don't have
it yet, but coming soon.
AUDIENCE: Fantastic.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What's, like, a good
best practice for handling
negative comments?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Yeah, comments
are kind of the Wild
West of video.
One approach is you can
turn off comments, and
some brands do that.
We don't encourage that, because
it kind of cuts off
the community.
And we think that the best
comments will rise to the top,
in the top comments section.
We're also working on
some improvements to
the comments system.
So, hopefully, we'll have
an update on that in
the next few months.
AUDIENCE: I have a question on
best practices to limit the
visibility of videos, if you
have IP or something that
you're posting, you guys
thinking about doing,
basically, something similar to
circles, or do you have any
other ideas for controlling
IP and videos?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Yes, so
currently, we have three
privacy states for
YouTube video.
You can make it private, which
means you can specify a
limited number of people
to watch it.
You actually name them.
You can make it public, and
that's the other extreme.
And then we also have unlisted,
where only people
with the link will discover
the video.
If anyone gets the link, they
can watch it, but it's
security by obscurity.
We're also working on some
additional forms of sharing.
So stay tuned on that as well.
Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: Right now, is the
best option for this
community, live streaming on
YouTube, going through
Google+, and then using--
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ:
Hangouts on Air?
AUDIENCE: Hangouts on
Air back to YouTube.
That's the best live streaming
option right now?
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Yes,
that's the one that's
available to everyone.
We also have a live
streaming product.
But right now, that's available
to higher-end partners.
There's a lot of setup cost
involved in that, and it's not
yet a self-serve offering.
We hope to make that available
in the future.
But for now, Hangouts on
Air is your best bet.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
DROR SHIMSHOWITZ: Any
more questions?
Well, thanks everyone
for coming.
We're really excited about
the future of YouTube.
And we hope you jump on the
platform and help us build
this great platform for video
content going forward.
Thanks for coming.
AJ CRANE: Thanks.